bonne fête paul est venu me dire à ma
femme
bonne fête paulette et je lui donnerais
mon bouquet elle a horreur des fleurs
c'est justement je déteste ma femme
alors je vois pas pourquoi je lui aurait
offert des chocolats
paulette adore les chocolats moi j'aime
ou pas pour l'être alors soyons logiques
et pourtant bien précisé à ma mère je
vais dit je veux pas épousé paul est
elle m'a répondu on parle pas à table
bon mon père non plus les pauvres fous
de ma mère mais lui trente ans de
mariage
il a fait le plus gros le jour je
regarde ses jambes jeudi tête et bugs
qui plissent blanc aime retourne une
claque elle avait pas de bas j'ai dit à
ma mère paulette est moche même répond
paulette me ressemble je dis oui mais
toi tu es ma mère elle me répond
pourrais tu pourrais être ta mère bon
alors horreur des fleurs il va faire une
de ces tests mais fou j'aime pas sa tête
allait le mettre à la poubelle au prix
où sont les fleurs surtout les grains ne
savait pas plus de profits clécy
elle allait jeter c'est sûr je m'en
fiche d acheter avec l'argent des
commissions
il y remonte mois des escalopes j'ai
horreur des escalopes se dégoûte
elle s'en remet sur la figure c'est un
rêve que pour sortir donc oui où sont
les escalopes c'est que leveaux s'est
pas donné un choix figure dans un sens
si j'avais épousé une beauté je
m'ennuyais il paraît que les mannequins
les actrices c'est très ennuyeux surtout
le jour moi j'aime bien engagé la
conversation paulette elle parle elle
dit des bêtises beaucoup de bêtises
c'est normal parce qu'elle est bête
sa pratique parce que je comprends pas
ce qu'elle dit bruxelles et les filles
intellectuelle faut pas croire c'est la
barbe est sorti de l'intelligence et de
la culture
elles ont pas à grand chose peut-être
une bonne fête paulette salle énerve que
je l'appelle paulette tel concept commun
son vrai nom c'est germaine je l'appelle
paulette pour lui rabaissé son caquet
véritable soupe au lait n'empêche que si
je m'écoutais il ya des soirs je la
saisis différents villages holmes et guy
la couper en petits morceaux et on
trouverait jamais 104 sainement ça
serait dans le journal avec sa photo
alors écoutez le seul plaisir de ma
journée c'est de prendre mon petit crème
le matin tranquille à la terrasse de
chez lui
en lisant mon petit journal alors si
c'est pour retrouver les photos de
paulette en première page
bonne fête follett